c'est un bateau de l'an 2000 alors là ça
c'est le moteur que c'est l'accusé
personnel du commandant parce que quand
il coulera une dame dans l'an 2000 qu'il
cherchait le soleil le printemps d'envoi
nous paie toi
moi c'est un bonhomme qui qui a refusé
un petit compteur dans un puits il veut
il veut faire payer les gens parce que
comme il n'ya pas de fleurs et ben et le
public à kindu fleuret qu'un peu la
campagne
les maisons seront comme ça ça ce serait
une la mairie la maison la mairie alors
quand le maire voudrait aller sur la
lune
eh bien il mettrait les réacteurs en
marche
et puis ça partirait alors sa maison
partir elle y reste sur la lune alors
pis si la mairie et l'aurait un tuyau
puisse attirer tous les nuages comme ça
irait beaucoup de soleil observait
jamais de nuages et ça servirait pour
ravitailler la piscine qui sera ici tu
contre l'idée la fusée ans nina parce
que par exemple ce que tout le monde
veut partir sa femme ne se clôt mieux va
il sera obligé de partir pour les gratte
ciel parce que ça prend beaucoup moins
de place lou sera un immeuble en y aura
plus petites maisons y aura plus rien
plus de pavillons une campagne
de 2 4 août
je crois qu'il se nourrir est beaucoup
plus de choses artificielle chimiques
que deux choses naturelles comme mange
niveau que manger des fruits
il dira au travail que leurs membres une
pilule aux vitesses alors le dimanche
les lieux ce qu'ils travailleraient pas
eh ben il mangera repent ils mangeraient
des pilules que le jour férié
l'élu fait ça serait un peu pour les
pauvres et les forces pour aller
travailler et puis aussi il y aurait
beaucoup le mardi gras
il y aura les plus grosse crêpe
on
que pensez-vous des moyens de transport
en 1/2
arnaud moi je vois ça comme ça fait des
chacun circulerait avec une sorte de
capsule et ça je pense que les vieux
moyen de transport de l'an 2000 ça
serait une auto comme ça qu'est moyen de
transport seront très moderniser et on
ira sur la lune est allé sur la lune ce
sera rapide
grosse grosse histoire comme en ce
moment moi je pense que chaque homme
aura un moteur qui se mettra dans le dos
pour voler comment seront les métiers à
l'an 2000
il suffira d'appuyer sur un bouton puis
tous croient mécaniquement je crois pas
de quand même qu'ils auraient des robots
mais pourquoi voir si ça marche tout
électriquement avec des robots comme tu
dis un feu il y aura plus de travail
pour les chômeurs et tous ces gens là il
sera obligé de traîner dans les rues et
prier et ouvrait pour ainsi dire de faim
mais non parce qu'il faudra bien des
hommes pour faire marcher les robots ou
voulurent bout enfin certains imaginent
des bonhommes qui marche comme ça là moi
je crois que c'est des machines qui qui
parle dans promu machine à laver le
linge d'une machine à laver la vaisselle
comme je suis pas moi et ben moi moi moi
je dis que c'est ça un robot parce que
ça remplace ce que fait l'homme
les gens ils n'auraient plus rien à
faire parce qu il ne travaillerait plus
une fois qu'ils auraient des robots y
aurait des robots pour fabriquer des
robots et il ne travaillerait plus les
robots furent élagueurs et les gens
grossirait il ne ferait plus rien
d'israël il aurait
je suis pas il grossirait je crois que
la race de l'homme se perd 20
je
e
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'école
alain demi dans l'an 2000 l'école y aura
un peu moins de grammaire et quelques
unes mais hier beaucoup de dessin à
l'école vient presque plus besoin de
mettre devant chaque élève y aura une
sorte de télévision à côté de lui il ya
machine à écrire puis dictera par
exemple comme eddahbi sartrouville alors
sur les camps penser créole 40 milles je
ne suis pas d'accord j'en ai une
téléviseurs du bornou parce que quand
comme ça on n'apprend pas parce que si
on voit la réponse est tout de suite
comme ça on l'apprend la grande rien
allant de billes les maîtres sera chez
lui puis il parlera à 6 g et à ses
élèves qui seront chacun dans leur
maison et puis qui feront leur dicter
ses six la nano va travailler alors les
l'élève et il peut aussi bien coupés
sont acquis walkie et puis aller faire
des bêtises
moi je pense que en l'an 2000 peut-être
que l'écho que tout sera changé mais je
pense que l'école sera pas un traquenard
on pourra parler de jeu des loisirs et
des vacances
si la cuisine meubles et bien il y aura
pu regardera plus du hac en tant que
voix et la compagnie ben il refuse il y
aura toujours avérée des montagnes ne
rentre pas toujours un lino des vacances
seront coup sur la lune s'il reste de la
place
une syrah la mère trouve que trois mois
de vacances et bah c'est beaucoup trop
long
alors je voudrais qu'il ya plutôt à un
mois et demi ou bien au nom de morges en
a beaucoup moins deux mois et demi
moi j'ai dit qu'il y aurait 8 police et
que ce serait mieux que chacun s'occupe
de soi même et qui a pu président ni
riaz joua pas pourquoi il y aurait pas
de police parce que la police ait pas
fait que pour rechercher les bandits
c'est fait aussi pour la circulation
ça serait mieux d'avoir un policier dans
chaque maison il y aura un policier est
par exemple dans un immeuble en aurait 4
je sais pas moi et on le paye really il
vivra avec nous on our ' comme un fanny
à ce que je comprends il défendra les
policiers d'ailleurs le policier s'il
avec un voleur et défendre l honneur par
lire un volet en hand mais les hommes
sont beaucoup plus rare mais aiguë
pensons que toute cette toutes ses armes
ça devait ça devrait bien leur servir à
quelque chose heures ils font beaucoup
plus de guerre et il y aura beaucoup
plus de l'acheter parce qu'il y aura
encore des pays qui ne seront pas autant
armés qu'eux et ils les attaques en ce
moment je suis pas d'accord de loi parce
que les les genres où la bombe atomique
le monde aura la bombe atomique et puis
tout le monde aura peur et les guerres
arrêteront il y aura une grande guerre
mon avis il y aura une grande révolution
on peut dire parce que les les gens il
ya les présidents tout ça qui ordonne la
guerre il y envoie des soldats
mais les présidents ils seront pas tués
pour avoir le pays
alors moi je crois qu'il ya il y aura
une grande révolution des soldats contre
les contrôles les tacles pour les
gouvernements peut-être qu'en l'an 2000
il n'y aura plus de guerre parce que la
terre sera qu'un seul pays je l'avais
djerba il vaut mieux ce que le monde
soit qu'un seul pays qu'on parle
seulement une langue parce que c'est
s'applique aux les guerres je crois pas
que ça empêchera les guerres parce que
si un homme découvre methot une mine
d'or
il appellera ses amis et si ses amis
préviennent d'autres hommes
ils disputeront la mine d'or et cela
n'empêchera pas les guerres
les mariages alors devenir surtout les
journaux féminins que je regarde
car ici tout le monde est contre le
mariage coeur moi je dis qu'on l'an 2000
y aura plus de mariage
voilà pourquoi es tu contre le mariage
est bien parce que premier je crois que
ça sert à rien pas cercle l'homme que la
dame là le même nom que moi je suis pour
le mariage ou d'une autre façon je
supprime le truc d'aller chine que le
pire est déjà passé une bague au doigt
c'est tout moi je moi je sais pas
comment cette pierre public
le mariage est inutile c'est parce que
quand on voit des jeunes dans la rue qui
se rendent pas bien compte de ce qu'il
faut il voit une fille comme ça qu'ils
se promènent et tout ce qu'ils ont envie
de l'épouser mais sans blague et faris
et passer devant monsieur le curé salé
pris un tour réfléchir et ils prennent
la précaution de ce qu'ils font mais
plus tard y agira presque plus d'enfants
parce que c'est celle qui donne tu
donnes une sorte de graines là à la fac
puis la femme étaient des enfants alors
finalement tu as de quoi mais bon y'a
plus l'enfant mais elle en demi les fans
commandes 7 + tv ce sera fait les
indifférents les baisers
prom achèterait une pilule plus qu'on la
plantera dans la terre et puis que le
bébé pousse à je ne vois pas pourquoi on
de voir planter une pilule dans pas
longtemps peut-être qu'en l'an 2000
eh ben c'est sûr certains on fera des
bébés avec une graine qui sortira à
tubes
que pensez vous de la mode en l'an 2000
on sera habillé de colin qui ferait de
la tête aux pieds pour les femmes il y
aura une petit tube qui serait très
courte
les hommes 11 auront des chapeaux de
très hâte forme ils seront des longues
robes jusqu'aux pieds les fameux
porteront des gros chapeau de paille ou
quelquefois il se verrait en bermuda il
y aura des grands très grands cheveux
les hommes et les femmes et que la mode
sera des grands cycles descendent comme
il y aura plus de fleurs dans parce que
ce soit que des immeubles et bien il y
aura des robes à fleurs et les femmes
pour que comme ça sentirait rien va
semer strauss cologne dessus comme ça
les fleurs que ce qu elle qui aura sur
les robes blanches sortir vous
[Musique]